is there one structure upon which almost
every story will fit into yes I was
there's a lot of controversy about that
like love controversy is about structure
because this is something that everybody
teaches and everybody likes to have
their own version of it so you got you
know you got Michael eggs you got Mikey
you got troubie you know hero's journey
saved the cat's the key so here's the
thing about structure so I believe in
structure I think everything in life is
structured the way we appreciate story
is structured you know it's we we are
we've evolved to understand appreciate
stories because of the way they're
shaped okay so you know Mike even
Goldsman for example talks about how in
the fashion industry every shirt looks
like a shirt even though it may be a
different different cut different
material whatever but a shirt looks like
a shirt that is the structure of a shirt
the structure of a human being is the
skeleton all skeletons look the same
no matter what is on top of it right
even though as human beings were all
different but the skeleton if you rip
off all of our stuff will look the same
right that means all humans means have
the same structure if if a human being
didn't have a skeleton there'll be like
a ragdoll pieces on them on the floor
right there they would not exist the
same with their stories unstructured
stories are not as appreciated as
structured stories at least that's my
experience no matter how you label it it
doesn't matter doesn't matter what you
label the inciting event doesn't matter
what you label the beginning the middle
or end it's still structure and so all
stories are structure all stories have
the same structure not not necessarily
you know that whole thing that they
teach you which i think is ridiculous
the page numbers say okay this has to
happen on page 12 and if it's not you're
doomed
that's silly or that you have to have an
insight you know well all stories have
an inciting event that's that but the
whole thing about you know midpoints or
all is lost darkest moment and dark now
there's all this stuff there's
exceptions to that but most stories have
the shape of stories which is you know
rising tension climax resolution that's
kind of in arguable I think so I'm a big
believer in structure now in terms of
the actual labels that's up to you to
decide I mean the way I learned
structure was to basically read
everything and to really kind of like
learn what other people have said from
the beginning and kind of if it didn't
resonate with me then I didn't absorb it
but there's there's always something
where you something does resonate with
you and you suddenly understand it and
so you adapt that to your own work do
your own term lessons your own craft so
you know my my labels for structure
might have little pieces from all the
different ones from that has been talked
so far and that's what works for me
doesn't it so I mean that it would work
for someone else you know so it's up to
you it's up to the writer to really
study all forms and really understand
why that is that's the most important
thing and when you think about stories
when I talk about the power of stories I
I kind of show why stories are shaped to
where they are it's kind of the way
we're we're conditioned to accept them
and if they're not there that was weird
that doesn't fit it doesn't seem like a
story or something and so something will
be missing and that's I think that's
that happens a lot from writers who
don't know structure or try to say well
structure doesn't exist or whatever
negative connotation therefore structure
which is so it's gonna make me uncreate
evander be like cookie cutter formula
and all the stuff people say about
structure well I do show a slide of
human beings that look different and
when you take away all the stuff and you
show skeletons those skeletons look the
same so you can art argue that human
beings don't or don't have the same
structure they do at the same structure
but we all look different
it's the same with stories stories all
have the same structure but they all
look different
Ryan's feel most of you know this is
with Cooper Ross and she talks about the
stages of grief right you know and you
know not quite jive what its anger did
not like right yes ceptin right oh right
yeah that's the structure of grief yeah
which is pretty amazing comparison right
yeah but there's a natural progression
yeah yeah I I've I've known writers who
create their stories based on our grief
structure yeah I'm saying okay so more
power to them that's another structure
yeah
you